j'accueille Stéphane Guillon
en commençant janvier 2006 Cécilia
revient place Beauvau le 5 exactement le
5 pour l'ouverture des sols
en février après cette fait dévorée par
son chien Isabelle dinoir dévoile à la
presse son nouveau visage une seule
crainte le retour d'Isabelle chez elle
son chien allait-il la reconnaître
mars les bronzés dépassent le cap des 10
millions d'entrées le film pas
l'immigration effrayant pas parce
qu'elle Sevran c'est pas 10 millions de
bits évidemment
le même mois Nicolas Sarkozy inaugure sa
statue au musée Grévin statut grandeur
nature donc très économique en cire
si vous la placez à côté de celle de
Georges Bush la réhaus c'est
impérativement avec un cube Chirac c'est
trois cubes
avril la grippe aviaire frappe
l'Hexagone en soutien Dominique de
Villepin mange du poulet le lendemain
défilé de prostituées en faire et là
aucun geste de la part du ministre qui
aurait pu s'en taper une ou deux quand
même en soutien
une année placée sous le signe des
animaux gris pavières chikungunya
Navarro qui perd son mulet la nouvelle
star qui plébiscite une tortue deux ours
femelles lâchés dans les Pyrénées une
troisième qui retrouve du boulot sur le
câble et blind Thomas
avril 20e anniversaire de la catastrophe
de Tchernobyl commémoré partout sauf en
France je vous rappelle que le nuage
toxique avait fait un détour pour nous
éviter en Ukraine la spécialité locale
reste le poulet à six pattes les enfants
sont contents il y a du blanc pour tout
le monde
mais guide rue admistier par Chirac 15
mois de prison qui saute pour service
rendu dans le domaine du sport à ce
qu'on classe Zidane beaucoup plus titrée
pourrait être trucidé sa femme butter un
flic ou égorger une petite vieille
au sommet de l'OTAN Poutine clou le bec
de dictionnaire un Poutine très en forme
mais légèrement dégarné il paraît que le
soir dans sa chambre d'hôtel et mettez
au point un cocktail thé vert et
polonium juillet 2006 le plus chaud
depuis 50 ans en France malheureusement
on a eu un mois d'août pourri et les
vieux ont pu récupérer
l'idéal ce serait un juillet 2006 et
tout de suite derrière un août 2003 vous
voyez la canicule Gilette de lame et là
on ferait une vraie économie sur nos
cotisations retraite
août le 11 chute à vélo de Richard
Virenque et Charles qui depuis ce jour
détient la meilleure imitation de Franck
Ribéry
septembre Amélie Nothomb sort son livre
comme tous les mois de septembre la
rentrée des classes les impôts et un
livre d'Amélie Nothomb c'est malheureux
mais c'est comme ça
octobre Véronique courgiot congèle trois
bébés Madonna en adopte un Que Choisir
s'endormir doucement la tête posée sur
un sac de poissons pané Picard ou
supporté pendant 18 ans Madonna elle est
préceptes de la Kabbale
novembre ça y est le cocktail de Poutine
est prêt je vous l'avais annoncé en juin
décembre s'il était lu Sarkozy annonce
un ministère de l'immigration à sa tête
Johnny Hallyday qui donne l'exemple en
émigrant en Suisse ministre de la
Culture Stevie régulation des naissances
parce qu'elles Sevran santé contrôle des
stupéfiants Doc Gynéco ministre de
l'Intérieur Jean Reno famille et
cohésion du couple sa femme Cécilia à la
semaine prochaine merci beaucoup
sésame Guillaume non pas pour une revue
de presse de la semaine mais pour une
revue anticipée de l'année 2016 on
t'écoute janvier Pascal Sevran opéré de
la prostate mais oui il avait l'âge
février mort de Michael Jackson
Bambi repose à Disney à la droite de
Pinocchio quand les enfants quand les
enfants touchent Pinocchio sont nés
grandis quand il touche Bambi
février toujours le 23 sortie du nouveau
CD de Carla Bruni un album plébiscité
par Miss Limousin qui est sourde
mars encore un bébé caché pour Albert de
Monaco sont 3ème si vous avez couché
avec le prince la Principauté met en
place un numéro vert le
08103000
avril Dieudonné ouvre un café théâtre à
thé en je suis venu ici pour voir pour
observer par un du lieu Bruno goldnisch
qui était présent en décembre au Zénith
dans le carré VIP
vere importante pourriture
mai 2007 défaite de Nicolas Sarkozy à la
présidentielle d'origine hongroise le
président de l'UMP quitte la France
victime de sa propre loi sur
l'immigration choisie
reconversion des Sarkozy à Budapest dans
une entreprise de Karcher Nico la
propreté qu'il vous faut
Ségolène Royal élu présidente de la
République François Hollande devient
première dame de France
énorme déception de Jack Lang qui
briguait ce poste
juin il inauguration de la ligne TGV
Paris est Bernadette Chirac qui n'est
plus première dame de France sauf un
ultime voyage avec David Douillet
surnommé son gros sumo lubrique des U
shimata torride les derniers couchés sur
des sacs de pièces jaunes
juillet libération d'Ingrid Bettencourt
les ravisseurs ont cédé aux chanteurs
Renaud qui menaçaient d'écrire un album
entier en soutien à l'otage
août la canicule basse en plein à Paris
plus de 35 degrés dans le métro
peut-être le moment d'offrir une carte
orange à Mamie
5 millions moins enfin une vraie
économie sur nos cotisations retraite
ou toujours en Une de voici Claire
Chazal sinus sur une plage Corse à côté
Philippe t'auraison bouquine en faisant
la tronche un été classique
septembre Amélie Nothomb sort une grosse
merde chez album Michel décidément les
années se suivent et se ressemblent
novembre Molière de la meilleure actrice
Adriana Karembeu dans septembre
réflexion Miss France 2008 madame de
Fontenay elle-même bah si si c'est
possible si adriana est meilleur actrice
madame de Fontenay peut être Miss France
prix Nobel de la Paix Pascal Sevran
c'est l'année de tous les excès
fin novembre un message de détresse en
provenance de Suisse ah que je m'emmerde
décembre Isabelle dinoir la greffée du
visage a eu un bébé avec Franck Ribéry
un garçon un garçon prénommé Picasso
voilà
la semaine prochaine je reprends le
cours de l'actu ça va saigner merci
voilà c'était Stéphane Guillon merci
Stéphane politique Sarkozy a une
sexualité étrange regardez ses photos il
ferme la bouche pour embrasser sa femme
mais il ouvre pour serrer la main d'un
homme
déviance toujours pour faire ressortir
sa féminité Michel Alliot-Marie exige
que nos militaires se déguisent en drag
queen
Bertrand Delanoë sans état d'âme
derrière Ségolène Royal titre libération
bah oui mais bon où est l'info derrière
une femme Bertrand n'a jamais eu d'état
d'âme
après le scandale des viandes avariées
perquisition chez les éleveurs de porc
le QG du Front national a été contrôlé
Ségolène Royal refuse de se rendre à
Deauville parce que c'est une ville de
riche fidèle à ses convictions elle
passe ses vacances dans un quartier très
difficile sur la Côte d'Azur à Mougins
une zone de non-droit ou après 19h on
peut se faire attaquer par des cigales à
8000 euros le mètre carré c'est Go est
condamné à payer les SF pour vivre dans
ce bouge c'est terrible avec la même
bravoure Ségolène a assisté à
l'avant-première du film de Christophe
Malavoy alors là bravo elle est
ressortie complètement bouleversée
métamorphosides
international une mission très difficile
confie à Madame de Fontenay organiser
l'élection de Miss taliban
international toujours Renaud renonce à
soutenir Ingrid Bettencourt pour une
vraie cause humanitaire la
réhabilitation de vieux animateurs
méchants et gris il y a du taf
société dans VSD un reportage sur les
mamans sexagénaires à quand une mère
octogénaire une formule très économique
en cas d'incontinence de la maman elle
peut se servir des couches de bébé
[Rires]
on va passer à table c'est bien
record de naissance en France 830 000
nourrissons en 2006 autant de bébés
frais c'est une aubaine pour le coup en
inutile d'en congeler on a ce qu'il faut
vie pratique les soupes Liebig affiche
des noms de plus en plus affriolants
partage entre amis réconfort divers
enfin si vraiment vous aimez la soupe la
mélasse vous avez aussi ensemble tout
devient possible
merci Christophe
faits divers une prof de tango décapitée
c'est emmerdant c'est quand tu danses le
tango le moment le plus gracieux c'est
quand tu renverses la tête de ta
partenaire et si elle en a plus c'est
chiant musique
Chimène Badi déclare d'angala ce que je
ressens sur scène et parfois plus fort
qu'un orgasme ça tombe bien on préfère
l'applaudir que coucher avec
[Applaudissements]
people inquiétude du Parisien Stéphane
Bern devra-t-il se raser la tête pour
jouer dans le prochain Jean-Pierre Mocky
alors je rassure le Parisien je connais
bien Stéphane inutile de le raser faut
juste bien décoller sa moumoute et il
peut travailler
après la publication dans match de
photos d'un j.i défiguré
Régine renonce à entreprendre un nouveau
lifting
dans VSD un spécial monstre marin le
dragon noir la lotte épineuse et
également présente à la soirée paris
Première la José Dayan
[Rires]
people toujours stupeur lors d'un gala
caritatif sur le thème du cirque Zidane
aurait mis un coup de boule à sa monture
littérature un ouvrage de poésie
érotique signé Serge Lama je le cite les
vagins sont des carrefours où se
côtoient vite et bouche c'est beau on
dirait du Pascal Sevran sauf que Pascal
les vagins il les évite et les [ __ ] si
elles sont noires il les coupent
on termine par un scoop après les photos
de Jean-Luc Delarue nu à Saint-Barth une
autre photo volée et là peut-être un
début d'explication assez complexe parce
qu'elle se vend à la plage
[Rires]
pour votre revue de presse de la semaine
Stéphane j'ai des scoops politiques
cette semaine Thierry et c'est du béton
j'ai tout piqué à la source à la cellule
d'espionnage de Nicolas Sarkozy
dimanche au Front national on a tiré les
rois présents Dieudonné a refusé de
faire Balthazar
plainte dans la banlieue de montré tout
un gentil doberman a promener un bipède
extrêmement dangereux sans laisse et
sans muselière
et puis
on connaît enfin l'origine des
fulgurances de François Bayrou des
bourrins les lui murmures à l'oreille
après sa plaisanterie sur le couple
royal Hollande au Grand Journal Arnaud
Montebourg peaufinent son skate la
Madone et le culbuto bientôt Jamel
Comedy Club
Bernard Kouchner et René Souchon sont
peut-être de bons conseils mais ils ont
une haleine de bouc observez la main de
la candidate
une info libération Ségolène et François
font chambre à part mais
QG commun c'est très sec du partage
l'agrafeuse le taille-crayon est parfois
le faxagène encre
ce week-end Ségolène est aux Antilles
elle aurait dû y aller avec Georges
Frêche qui trouve qu'il y a trop noir en
équipe de France comme elle fait
toujours une gaffe en déplacement là tu
l'as fait dès le départ tu gagnes du
temps
un policier puni pour avoir dormi dans
le lit présidentiel ça ne pourrait pas
arriver à Sarkozy le lait est trop petit
tu dors les jambes pliées tu es pas bien
société un bracelet électronique pour
retrouver les bébés enlevés où sont-ils
dans le congélateur la cheminée ou au
fond de la Bologne
bébé toujours ouverture d'un resto du
coeur pour les nourrissons j'espère que
Patrick Fiori ne va pas chanter ou
encore ça va l'oreille est faite mais
tout petit comme ça ça les flingue
mais après une deuxième grève du visage
réussi une nouvelle exploit pour
l'équipe du professeur l'entierry une
actrice d'environ 60 ans s'est faite
greffer le corps d'une jeune fille de 17
Ariel Dombasle c'est son nom
les macaches les cicatrices faut que ça
sèche
[Rires]
ouais mais bon
on passe à table
[Applaudissements]
télévision en France 2 vire sont
directeur des programmes Jean-Baptiste
Jouy Patrick de Caroli flête pour une
télé stérile si tu souhaites couper la
[ __ ] des Noirs tu gardes ton poste si tu
t'appelles jouit tu dégages
on y jouit plus mais on s'éclate l'île
de la tentation à l'Élysée le 11 février
prochain Michel Drucker et sa chienne
Olga iront interviewer le chef de l'État
sur sa relation avec Bernadette
sur TF1 Claire Chazal va danser au
profit d'une association admirait la
reine du 20h dans un très bel
assouplissement fessier totalement
détendu offerte quelques secondes plus
tard Philippe t'auraison complétera la
position
[Rires]
Dalida entre dans le domaine public une
mauvaise nouvelle pour Orlando son frère
à 71 ans généralement on perd sa
prostate lui perd sa bourse
[Rires]
toujours Amanda
et des lettres présents à la cérémonie
sont compagnon manuel cazella c'est la
première fois qu'un chevalier vient
chercher sa médaille avec sa monture
[Rires]
merci Stéphane
le scooter volé du fils Sarkozy
retrouvait grâce à des prélèvements ADN
Sarkozy faut pas l'emmerder on lui a
piqué sa femme l'an passé pareil elle a
été retrouvée ils avaient tout hein
c'est mensurations son numéro de châssis
l'état de la carrosserie et un
certificat de non-gage et comme quoi
elle était plus avec Jacques Martin
le philosophe André Glucksmann rejoint
les personnalités soutenant Sarkozy faut
qu'il fasse une boulette maintenant
assez obligé émigré en Suisse rouler
bourré dans un couloir de bus ou
déclarer qui veut couper la [ __ ] des
noirs
à Orange un élu UMP avait transformé sa
villa en bordel l'établissement a été
fermé je vois pas pourquoi c'est pile
poil les valeurs de l'UMP écrites dans
le Figaro cette semaine travail autorité
responsabilité masturbation fait la
science
à Paris les habitants de la rue
d'Enghien où se trouve le QG de Sarkozy
se plaignent les RG les aurait
interrogés et fichiers faut pas
s'énerver la rue d'Enghien est une rue
test si Nicolas était lu ce sont toutes
les rues de France qui seront
interrogées et fichiers on voit si ça
marche
le pire c'est être noir et habiter rue
d'Enghien contrôlé par Sarkozy castré
par Sevran
on passe au Parti socialiste faut être
équitable dans la saloperie sinon le CSA
se fâche
Ségolène Royal a déjoué un canular
téléphonique de Gérald Dahan se faisant
passer pour François Hollande Géral de
lui a proposé une nuit coquine à la
permanence du PS ouais c'était trop gros
comme ficelle sur les proposer un débat
participatif ou une visite de Jarnac
sur les marchés et les socialistes
installent des boîtes à idées alors
soyez gentils mettez pas de conneries
dans les boîtes style la Corse
indépendante ou vive le Québec libre
parce que vous vous savez que c'est pour
rire mais ces golem
dans match un reportage sur Ségolène
jeune fille au Père ah bah voilà tout
s'explique c'est là qu'elle a fait ses
armes en politique tais-toi virgule
mange ta soupe point partage avec ton
voisin point d'exclamation
à Rome lors d'un défilé de haute couture
un styliste a proposé une robe Ségolène
Royale une robe Dominique Voynet est à
l'étude pour les femmes qui en ont marre
que leur mari leur saute dessus tous les
soirs il paraît que ça fait débander
tout de suite ça et du déodorant Ushuaïa
sous les bras vous êtes sûr de ne plus
être emmerder société
en Mayenne record de natalité 33
naissances pour 1663 habitants va
falloir équiper le secteur en
congélateur
ça c'est pour Gaccio c'est je sais qu'il
aime bien
je dis on ne fume plus dans les lieux
publics 175 000 fonctionnaires font
appliquer la loi à des fonctionnaires on
va déjà on pourra fumer entre midi et
deux l'après-midi à partir de 16h les
jours fériés et au mois de mai avec tous
les pompiers pour un cloper tant qu'on
veut
[Applaudissements]
dire les fonctions ouais c'est vrai
maintenant c'est vrai que tu as des
fonctionnaires qui bossent ou je sais
pas
cinéma
unanimité autour de l'île au trésor film
avec Gérard Jugnot pour le Parisien un
naufrage pour le JDD un sabordage pour
VSD une piraterie infestée par l'ennui
si votre enfant a mal travaillé à
l'école emmenez-le ça ou un conte de
Marlène Jobert généralement il s'en
souviennent
déclaration de Jean-Pierre Mocky
Stéphane Bern physique de cinéma
il y a pas de vanne c'est ça la vanne
télévision une interview de Marc-Olivier
Fogiel ma dernière rencontre avec l'abbé
Pierre on espère que c'est pas ça qui
l'a tué
on termine par une nouvelle qui réjouira
Pascal Sevran bientôt une pilule pour
homme bloquera l'éjaculation c'est moi
douloureux qu'un coup de ma chaîne sur
la [ __ ] à la semaine prochaine merci
bravo
à vous Stéphane pour votre revue de
presse de la semaine
rassurez-vous Thierry je ne dirai rien
sur les caricatures de Mahomet dans ma
chronique pour des raisons d'assurance
vie essentiellement je vais dire un truc
sans risque Benoît XVI est une raclure
et là je peux rentrer à la maison en
sifflotant donc une chronique très noire
Thierry mais légèrement couille molle
politique bientôt à la retraite Chirac
s'entraîne au jeu question pour un
champion comment expulser les sans
papiers de façon plus humaine c'est au
rayon boucherie à Rungis que Nicolas
Sarkozy a eu une idée tiens si on les
pendait par les pieds
une info incomplète du Figaro je vous la
lis samedi en fin d'après-midi Ségolène
s'est offert une heure de bonheur sous
la tente Pierre Bérégovoy alors qui a
offert une heure de bonheur à Ségolène
on ne sait pas après les débats
participatifs les ébats participatif
aussi
pas facile de travailler après un câlin
regardez cette photo trois qui bossent
une qui revasse
comme tous les lieux publics l'Élysée
est non-fumeurs aucun changement pour
Bernadette et Jacques qui ne fumaient
qu'après avoir fait l'amour
dernière cigarette grillée en 77 à
l'hôtel de ville
Bernadette a-t-elle refumé dans le TGV
Piaggio jaune seul David Douillet
connaît la réponse
après nous avoir piqué les Jeux
Olympiques de 2012 nouveau revers pour
Bertrand Delanoë l'Angleterre accueille
la grippe aviaire
le maire de Paris va construire des
bureaux dans des tours de 200 mètres de
haut avec très peu de parking donc tu
peux plus fumer tu peux plus de garer tu
peux te jeter
ouverture des tours Mike Brant en 2010
[Applaudissements]
médecine le greffé du visage c'est rasé
la barbe il paraît qu'il était furieux
bah il est brun et ils lui ont mis une
Barberousse elle est vraiment et son âge
je m'en foutisme ces médecins c'est
vraiment une américaine a présenté à la
presse son bras biomécanique 22
fonctions possibles elle peut battre des
œufs faire du stop dire ce qu'elle pense
de bouche
satisfaire son mari ou casser des noix
on espère
on espère que c'est bien réglé
vie pratique la lingerie réparatrice à
la cote sans rembouret fausses fesses et
gaine compresses cellulite attention
trompe l'oeil on séduit une fille on la
ramène chez soi et deux agrafes plus
tard ce n'est plus Laetitia Casta c'est
Évelyne Thomas
culture sortie du DVD Johny s'en va en
guerre
disponible également Johnny s'en va en
Suisse l'histoire d'un rocker qui a
troqué ses santiags contre des Moon
Boots il s'emmerde tellement que même
son répertoire change blanc c'est blanc
il n'y a plus d'espoir chiant c'est
chiant il neige tout le temps
[Applaudissements]
télévision invité de marque Olivier
Fogiel Alain Delon refuse de poireauter
et s'en va c'est normal dans la nature
c'est la même chose jamais un requin ne
fait patienter un guépard
en ce moment les gens partent souvent
des émissions
pas ici
nous présente ses jumelles
une véritable provocation pour Pascal
Sevran qui souhaite stériliser les noirs
peut-on sauver notre service public
s'interroge Alexandre Jardin peut-on
surtout sauver la littérature
d'Alexandre Jardin et on termine on
termine par le meilleur Arielle Dombasle
pose nu
la semaine prochaine la tête de la fille
de 18 ans qui a prêté son corps pour la
photo
sur le même principe Roger Hanin fera la
prochaine coupe du magazine
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
on vous écoute Stéphane
politique dans le Figaro un reportage
sur la Hongrie berceau de la famille
Sarkozy si Nicolas perd la
présidentielle on pourra le renvoyer
là-bas grâce à sa propre loi sur
l'immigration choisie
[Applaudissements]
lors de ces prestations télévisuelles
Sarkozy porterait une oreillette et
alors Ségolène aussi ce qui serait bien
c'est virer le gars qui lui souffle des
conneries à l'autre bout
[Applaudissements]
avec moi tout le monde en prend ça droit
de gauche
Sarkozy renonce à son projet sur le
suivi des malades mentaux dommage plus
d'espoir pour Doc Gynéco qui s'en tape
d'ailleurs d'après Le Figaro le cannabis
perturbe le processus de mémorisation du
cerveau un encéphalogramme plat
n'empêche pas de temps en temps une
fulgurance dans son livre le dock
déclare le chômage est facile à résoudre
il suffit de trouver du travail
problème de mémoire encore Dominique
voannet présente au procès de l'Erika à
l'époque ministre de l'Environnement
elle avait déclaré ce n'est pas une
catastrophe écologique non non c'était
juste une grosse mouette qui avait chié
le groupe Total refuse d'indemniser les
victimes de la marée noire et dorénavant
on ne viendra plus chez eux par hasard
suscite de la sœur de Laetitia d'Espagne
une certaine
Erika ne donnait pas le nom d'un
pétrolier à un enfant c'est difficile
problème de mémoire toujours sur TF1 les
téléspectateurs ont applaudis Jean-Marie
Le Pen après sa prestation à l'émission
j'ai une question à vous poser c'est un
nouveau chanteur Le Pen parce que moi je
croyais que c'était l'auteur du
calembour du Rafour crématoire je suis
con
un espoir justement pour les mémoires
défaillantes un vaccin contre la maladie
d'Alzheimer est à l'étude une première
tentative fut stoppée en 2001 après la
découverte de 18 cas danséphalite
heureusement les malades ne portent pas
plainte et se souviennent plus qu'on les
a vaccinés
lors du meeting de Ségolène à Villepinte
François Hollande a compris la vanne de
Montebourg avec trois semaines de retard
[Rires]
c'est le curage politique internationale
Poutine propose d'aider les Saoudiens en
matière nucléaire tant mieux en
radioactivité les super balaise il a
fait une démo sur linkevin and Co en
trois jours il était chaud en trois
semaines il était mort ceci était
attention attention grève des gardiens
de musée quand il travaille ils sont
assis dans un coin sans bouger donc
grève très difficile à détecter
voyage moyennant un supplément une
compagnie d'avion propose à ses
passagers une classe sans enfant
destination la Thaïlande la Thaïlande
beaucoup de gens y vont pour se taper
des enfants mais il ne les supporte pas
pendant le voyage
circulation de la Noé a-t-il tout faux
titre le point non il y a des choses
formidables les pistes cyclables
espérance de vie 400 mètres les couloirs
de bus de 6 mètres de large quand le bus
s'emmerde il peut zigzaguer et enfin ma
mesure préférée malheureusement il y a
eu une seule tentative la circulation
alternée ce jour-là seuls les numéros
impairs pouvaient rouler Paris 75 tout
le monde a pu rouler
[Applaudissements]
en Angleterre pourvu qu'il emmène Romane
Serda avec lui
on termine par le meilleur bientôt
n'expo Dalida à Paris les expos de
chanteurs morts j'adore ça bientôt une
expo Claude François sponsorisé par EDF
et également une expo Mike Brant tous
les visiteurs pourront sauter à
l'élastique à la semaine prochaine merci
beaucoup merci c'était Stéphane Guillon
alors Stéphane
cette revue de presse de la semaine
on a été gâté quand même sur la fin
politique à l'UDF André Santini a été
suspendue c'est dangereux la dernière
chose suspendue chez Santini c'était son
balcon
le couple Bayrou à la coque un sondage
Ifop bah forcément par rapport au
Sarkozy madame Bayrou n'est jamais parti
par rapport aux Hollande les bayrous
dorment ensemble et par rapport aux deux
Villiers aucun des 6 enfants byroux n'a
violé son frère
ça fait beaucoup
une info libération Sarkozy court après
les sportifs attention Nicolas couru
après sa femme pendant un an il est très
en forme
écologie Dominique buenesse s'est
adressée au chasseur je ne suis pas venu
faire une danse du ventre devant vous
heureusement
voilà qui montre son ventre si les gars
on leur fusil il tire la bécasse à plume
ça les excite
malgré le retrait de Hulot voanet
plafonne à 2%. c'est marrant on a beau
être écolo voisin candidate ça donne
envie de rouler en 4K
à Paris 7 heures de bouchon suite à un
accident sur le périphérique en vérité
c'est Bertrand Delanoë qui testait son
nouveau plan pour fluidifier par ici
un couloir de bus sur l'autoroute A10 ah
ça c'est une idée de la Noé rendre
l'autoroute piétonne
couloir de 30 mètres de large trottoir
géant pour la balade et piste cyclable à
contresens
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
justice les couples gays interdit
d'adoption il y a des contradictions les
homosexuels ne peuvent pas adopter
d'enfants en revanche on peut très bien
adopter un futur homosexuel
vis sociale la grève des gardiens de
musique continue pourtant sur cette
photo on voit que certains ont repris le
travail
people Jean-Luc Delarue pète les plombs
dans un avion inquiétude à France 2 bah
ils ont viré Ardisson pour un type
d'animateur plus consensuel 6 mois plus
tard tu en as un qui mord des stewards
l'autre qui veut castrer des Noirs
cela dit Sevran n'a jamais mordu un
steward au contraire
[Applaudissements]
résumons le steward tu peux le mordre tu
peux lui couper la [ __ ] tant que tu lui
dis pas je vais voter Bayrou France 2
passe l'éponge
Le Figaro consacre un article sur la
peur des people en avion 4 prises et
morsures le plus élégant reste le prince
Albert qui pour conjurer sa peur se tape
une hôtesse aux toilettes
la marraine retrouvée de Michel
Polnareff vous savez pas quand Orlando
c'était perdu
[Rires]
Gérard Jugnot déclare ne l'écrivait
surtout pas les vins de deuxpardieu sont
épouvantables alors c'est vrai cela dit
on peut les boire en regardant l'île au
trésor un bon navet arrosé d'une piquer
crotte c'est top et on termine par notre
coup de cœur Guy Carlier Joséphine d'art
attendre ton bébé
alors c'est elle qui est enceinte
et l'enfant s'appellera Antoine hommage
au travail de Frédéric Dard en hommage
au travail de Guy il aurait fallu
appeler le petit Marc Olivier Fogiel
c'est un coup à se faire casser la
gueule à la récré
merci anniversaire Gaston fête 50 ans de
gaffe une idole pour Ségolène ROYAL
pour Sarkozy la campagne présidentielle
c'est une forme d'oubli de soi oubliez
Sarkozy enfin une réforme qui nous tente
après c'est déboires Argenteuil Sarkozy
revient enfin en banlieue à Perpignan
Perpignan
Perpignan ça craint tu as des lieux
comme ça en France le Mont-Saint-Michel
la Promenade des Anglais tu as une
caillera locale des vieux avec des
caniches et là
inutile de les karcheriser surtout au
mois d'août être rafraîchi il manque que
ça
cosy aurait promis à Santini le
ministère de la Culture
Santini avec ses vannes pourri sa promet
le budget de la Comédie Française
allouée au Théâtre des Deux Ânes
super une super affaire Thierry si ça
vous intéresse dans les pages
immobilières du Figaro c'est l'agence
UMP qui propose ça
UMP urbanisme magouille et privilège
un duplex terrasse à Neuilly vue sur
scène 200000 euros c'est pas cher alors
dépêchez-vous il y en a qu'un après au
même prix c'est Clichy-sous-Bois
mais l'antenne parabolique est offerte
il y a un grand merci à Jacques Chirac
qui pour sauver les salariés d'Airbus ça
roulait une pelle à la chancelière
allemande ah ouais
et une semaine avant Sarkozy avait
essayé mais bon dans un pays où les
hommes mesurent en moyenne un mètre 90
Angela Merkel a refusé
après cette prononcé sur l'état de leur
patrimoine les candidats se prononcent
sur la grandeur de leur sexe
[Applaudissements]
en même temps il a plus sa prostate donc
c'est moins grave
fait divers un CRS accuse des policiers
de l'avoir violenté
des policiers qui tapent un CRS il y a
un truc qui cloche ah le CRS s'appelle
Jamel Boussetta
tout s'explique
à Paris un octogénaire à base de
personnes et ben voilà voilà il y a pas
eu de canicule l'été dernier résultat
les vieux pètent le feu Juliette Gréco
monte sur scène Orlando prépare une expo
Dalida et Arielle Dombasle au Crazy
Horse merci la météo
trois blessés par balle pendant un match
à La Courneuve c'était l'équipe de La
Samaritaine qui jouait
usage de latte couteau et armes à feu
décidément on trouve tout à la
Samaritaine
société dans VSD les photos d'un
milliard 280 g à la naissance un bébé
est très facile à congeler contrairement
aux petites courges
on peut en mettre 24 ça fait une crèche
une idée pour de la Noé
EDF 200 barrages menaces de CD au plus
électricité
si celui de serre-pousson lâche 200000
riverains rendraient un hommage à Claude
François
EDF il nous doit plus que la lumière
people Marie Drucker a présenté les
Victoires de la musique classique grande
mélomane Marie pratique avec son
compagnon le ministre François Baroin la
musique de chambre ouais 600 tinites à
la culture faut que je fasse des vannes
pourries désolé
dans la série nos vedettes s'affichent
avec des politiques une première de la
rue fait une connerie sans rejoindre le
clan Sarkozy
il y a un petit temps de
à partir d'aujourd'hui Jean-Luc se
visite au parc animalier de Thoiry vous
pouvez photographier l'animateur
attention ne faites pas comme cette dame
restait dans la voiture
Jean-Luc est atteint d'un mal très rare
très humain avec les animaux et très
animal avec les humains à la semaine
prochaine merci beaucoup salut
[Applaudissements]
politique une info libération Sarkozy
veut tester les immigrés exemple pour
trouver le futur Zidane organisons un
concours de dribble tous les immigrés
capables de passer trois rangées de CRS
balle au pied français
Sarkozy très inquiet par la situation
d'Airbus le futur gros porteur A380
aurait pu expulser 853 sans papiers d'un
coup ça fait trois bars HLM
l'UDF veut lancer des petits bayrous
partout ouais
miniaturiser Sarkozy non non
il disparaît
Simone Veil rejoint Nicolas Sarkozy bon
alors si elle l'accompagne à Argenteuil
les jeunes soyez gentils je sais qu'une
vieille avec un sac c'est très tentant
mais ne la traînez pas 30 mètres
derrière un scooter c'est quand même
madame veille
si Sarkozy passe Renaud donne Dieu de
Vabre souhaite conserver son ministère
quand il parle de culture même son chien
pionce
la villa de Ségolène Royal à Mougins
déclarait 270
000 euros office alors j'ai essayé de
trouver quelque chose à ce prix-là dans
la région j'ai fait une réunion
participative avec tous les agents
immobiliers dans ces prix il y a des
possibilités mais en dehors de Mougins à
Valbonne et c'est pas vraiment une ville
là c'est un camping-car mais c'est le
juste prix dans un monde juste
dans le magazine révolutionnaire gala
l'Alter mondialiste José Bové nous
présente sa maison écologique 100% pure
bois WC bio dégradable alors sachelingue
un peu mais comme José fume la pipe aux
toilettes ça va et au pire un coup de
déodorant Ushuaïa de chez Nicolas Hulot
Le Pen ne provoque plus de huer au salon
de l'agriculture
est-il passé inaperçu il y avait
énormément de ports cette année
[Applaudissements]
une nouveauté à un robot pour traire les
vaches
l'agriculteur célibataire peut
éventuellement s'en servir
politique internationale à tous les Jedi
qui ont perdu leur jambe George Bush
offre un magnifique plaid ornée de
drapeau américain
attention ce qui perdent les jambes les
bras et la tête gagne un plaid de luxe
justice à rrémiste condamné à un mois de
prison ferme pour le vol d'un sandwich
alors
problème de CP quand ils étaient à la
mairie de Paris les époux Chirac ont
déclaré 2 millions d'euros de bouche
partant du principe qu'un vol de
sandwich entraîne un mois ferme à quelle
époque de la préhistoire les chiracles
pour accomplir leurs peines
[Applaudissements]
l'ex directeur de voici mise en examen
150000 euros de pot de vin pour acheter
des reportages en même temps de l'argent
sale pour acheter des scouts de merde il
y a une logique merci
[Applaudissements]
société jeudi c'était la journée de la
femme Amanda Lear Martine Aubry et
Michel Alliot-Marie sont restés chez
elle
de plus en plus de skieurs s'élance avec
bébé dans le dos
si bébé est nu une façon de le congeler
tout en faisant du sport
[Applaudissements]
showbiz de la rue est-il encore légitime
pour présenter de grandes émissions
sociétales oui réponse France 2 Jean-Luc
sait faire accoucher les témoins quand
il refuse de parler il les morts et à ce
propos attention alors en exclusivité le
nouveau logo de la société de production
de Jean-Luc Delarue
inquiétude depuis que Philippe Torreton
a quitté Claire Chazal le comédien
s'habille en manteau de fourrure
[Rires]
match continue sa série nos vieilles
blondes se déploient après Arielle
Dombasle le mois dernier
c'est Michel Polnareff qui s'y colle
et on termine on termine par une info
qui ne concerne plus Orlando les Bourses
mondiales restent nerveuses
merci à la semaine prochaine merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
salon de l'agriculture Nicolas Sarkozy
c'est amour haché d'un animal à corne si
Cécilia repart il sera moins seul
une curiosité cette année un port coiffé
d'un chapeau de vache
voilà
et les crânes rasés autour sont en pot
de fesse
à force de penser comme des culs
Le Pen déguisé en cowboy titre La Presse
Jean-Marie aurait été chamboulé par le
film brockbeck Mountain autant vous dire
que dans sa commune à montre-tout c'est
les mois
Simone Veil récompensé pour son
ralliement à Sarkozy un dîner tendre
avec 12 stop Blazy qui est médecin
rappelons-le les vieilles adorent sortir
avec un toubib ça les rassure
Sarkozy est vraiment trop petit regardez
cette photo mardi à Vesoul il n'a pas pu
serrer la main de ces deux habitants qui
habitent pourtant un rez-de-chaussée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Bretagne protestation d'un village leur
malien ont été expulsés bah ce sont les
nouvelles directives du ministère de
l'Immigration et de l'Identité nationale
allez Malia avait tous un boulot breton
de puissance mais ils étaient incapables
de faire des crêpes il y a eu des
tentatives de crêpes maliennes mais
c'est pas ça ils mettent de l'ananas du
piment Sarkozy il a dit stop à l'école
Gilles de Robien veut réapprendre le
vocabulaire 5 mots nouveaux par semaine
or on commence dès maintenant le son
numéro unique
ta mère
pour avoir été mise sur écoute par
Mitterrand Carole Bouquet obtient
réparation un euro symbolique c'est pas
cher quand on pense à toutes les
douceurs que c'est fait ton temps en
écoutant les cassettes
international pékin veut réduire le
nombre des exécutions ah attention les
Chinois vont bientôt accueillir les JO
en tir ils sont très bons c'est
peut-être pas le moment d'arrêter
l'entraînement
dans VSD Samuel Le Bihan au Darfour face
à l'horreur sobriété de l'acteur qui
porte un t-shirt siglé action contre la
fin toujours au Darfour Bernard Henri
Lévy a préféré une veste Dior Polo Ralph
Lauren barbe de trois jours cheveux au
vent un balayage réalisé par Franck
Provost le coiffeur des stars
société vraie ou faux depuis le 1er
février 2007 de plus en plus de femmes
font le trottoir
faux ce sont juste des employés qui
descendent fumer une clope
[Applaudissements]
la société Kärcher en a marre qu'on
ridiculise son nom c'est vrai avec un
karcher on peut nettoyer une voiture des
poubelles et pendant la canicule on peut
hydrater mamie
si c'est moins cher qu'une thalasso
médecine une info libération d'une
région à l'autre les cancers sont plus
ou moins présents alors beaucoup de
cancers du sein en Haute-Normandie en
Basse-Normandie ce sont les cancers du
sein qui tombe et le Bas-Rhin c'est tout
ce qui est cancer du rectum et de la
prostate
sport le Paris Saint-Germain deuxième de
la Ligue 1 si si en partant du bas son
deuxième
chemise Paris Match a retrouvé les deux
derniers poilus il y a également Demis
Roussos qui n'a pas voulu poser le
fameux le Conseil d'Emmanuel Seigner il
n'y a pas que le cinéma dans ma vie je
peux rester trois ans sans bosser ça ne
me pose aucun problème c'est vrai on y
pense pas les caissières de supermarché
par exemple arrêtez-vous trois en
profiter
un scoop it antisémite pardon cérémonies
et on termine en images j'ai madame
guicarlier est enceinte première
échographie en 3D on voit déjà la trompe
et les deux grandes oreilles
à la semaine prochaine merci beaucoup
merci merci
on va se régaler il m'a dit que c'était
énorme aujourd'hui
c'est de l'énorme
politique trois jours avant le premier
tour Sarkozy lancera l'opération vague
bleue tous ces supporters devront porter
du bleu ça va être spectaculaire des
milliers de Schtroumpfs allant voter
pour Gargamel
au zénith Sarkozy parle d'amour devant
8000 jeunes vivaient aimer espérer ne
vous inclinez jamais quand tu aimes et
que tu es une fille il y a un moment il
faut savoir s'incliner
[Applaudissements]
c'est les 30 ans des grosses têtes dans
quelques jours
c'est de faire plaisir
toujours au zénith François Bayrou s'est
exprimé devant un auditoire conquis de
ce rôle des pelles un regard de sa
montre et les autres sont merde
en revanche quand c'est Ségolène qui
parle l'auditoire se passionne Martine
Aubry SMS Hollande booking de la Noé
guette un pote bloqué dans un couloir de
bus
selon François Bayrou Sarkozy ne peut
même plus entrer en banlieue faux la
semaine dernière il s'est rendu sur la
dalle des Invalides c'est forcément un
quartier super chaud regardez 25 canons
protègent le lieu contre la racaille
Nicolas Hulot n'apportera pas ses voix
Dominique Voynet pourtant elle met du
déodorant Ushuaïa elle a un physique
entièrement bio dégradable c'est injuste
politique internationale George Bush
demande plus de temps pour sa nouvelle
stratégie en Irak 200 000 morts
supplémentaires c'est tout et après
promis on discute
au Cameroun les pygmées sont battus
humiliés déplacés pour les soutenir la
visite de Dieudonné et Jenny Le Pen je
pense qu'il préfère être martyrisé
la logane cartonne en Irak ici personne
n'en veut elle est trop moche mais
là-bas tu as pas la honte quand tu la
conduite grâce à la burqa personne te
reconnaît
[Applaudissements]
faits divers incendie mortel dans une
maison de retraite une dame était en feu
c'est bien d'entraîner les vieux à
supporter la canicule mais quand même il
y a des limites
pas
[Applaudissements]
un étudiant guinéen tabassé par la
police des frontières sur son t-shirt
des empreintes de chaussures oui ce sont
les nouvelles directives du ministère de
l'Identité nationale pour
identifier un sans-papier tu appuies ta
Rangers sur son estomac
médecine dans le journal Le Monde un
reportage sur le cancer du colon ne
consultez pas pour rien dans six mois
avec les promesses électorales non
tenues on aura tous mal au cul c'est
normal
[Applaudissements]
société selon le journal Le Parisien la
mairie de Paris est motobe c'est exact
tout ce qui est casqué en cuir grosse
botte on n'aime pas Boo
en exclusivité le vélo mise à
disposition des Parisiens regardez le
bien son espérance de vie dans un
couloir de bus et le 150 mètres
[Rires]
présence d'amiante à la
Comédie-Française si on veut se
débarrasser de Mamie c'est peut-être le
moment de lui payer un abonnement
[Rires]
le scoutisme fête ses 100 ans un très
beau bilan 60
000 mise à l'air 30 000 bits aussi rage
et coup de chapeau également à la
bécottard qui lors d'une balade en mer
avait noyé 6 scouts pour la première
fois en France une collection d'animaux
préhistoriques mis en vente un ours des
cavernes un rhinocéros laineux et un
poster géant de régime
à Paris Jean-Paul Gaultier expose ses
vêtements admiraient ce modèle toujours
amusant de s'habiller comme une [ __ ]
les testicules sont au niveau des seins
et on termine par une photo rarissime en
pleine océan un plongeur à retrouver un
spermatozoïde de Guy Carlier
[Applaudissements]
une revue de presse entièrement
politique Thierry comme on a pas le
droit à la semaine prochaine
people
Ségolène Royal adore le bon vin cela
donne du plaisir toute la journée
dit-elle alors ça c'est la photo que
vous avez vu dans la presse et voici la
photo que vous n'avez pas vu en fin
d'après-midi
Ségolène a toujours du plaisir
Nicolas Sarkozy pense qu'on est
pédophile donc il y a des nourrissons
pédophiles s'ils sont excités par
beaucoup plus jeunes que à part un
hochet en forme de spermatozoïde je ne
vois pas
est-ce que les pédophiles voteront
Sarkozy mystère on sait juste les
reconnaître dans un isoloir
ces trash mais bon
Sarkozy toujours flashé à 130 sur une
route limitée à 70 oui c'est
l'application de son slogan ensemble
tout devient possible ensemble ça veut
dire deux motards pour ouvrir la route
un gyrophare et connaître le préfet et
là tu peux rouler comme un con sans
perdre de poids
on connaît mieux l'identité du
resquilleur de la Gare du Nord alors
contrairement à ce qui a été dit ce
n'est pas un délinquant
son avocat confesse de petits larcins
notamment un vol de nourriture 2
millions d'euros de frais de bouche et
des emplois fictifs rien de grave
l'image c'est important le petit-fils de
Chirac n'est pas flouté quand il est
avec son grand-père en revanche avec
Michel Alliot-Marie si
tu as à l'école c'est trop la honte tu
te fais emmerder
le coup de foudre Bayrou Lindon titre Le
Parisien il s'appelle 4 fois par jour
ouais c'est une vieille histoire quand
quand Bayrou est était bègue Vincent
Laidet à avec la tête
[Applaudissements]
Ségolène voudrait voir plus souvent son
compagnon Byron non il adore faire
campagne l'autre jour à Cayenne il a
dragué trois dans ce folklorique
il s'en est tapé aucune à force d'avoir
hésité entre celle de droite et celle de
gauche celle du centre lui a dit non
Jacques Lang et les infirmières bulgares
titres la presse à ne pas confondre avec
le film pornographique petite langue et
infirmière bulgare
s'il te plaît ça
la couverture de match berbadet Chirac
l'émotion du départ la première dame de
France visite une dernière fois les
pièces qu'elle a tant aimé
excusez-moi
dire que ça va être repris par Cécilia
qui sera à New York 6 mois sur 12
ça me fait mal au cul madame la baronne
en attendant Bernadette s'occupe la
voici à la lingerie l'Élysée où elle
raccourcit les draps oui pour Sarkozy
tout va être trop grand
un très beau reportage réalisé par Karl
Lagerfeld qui lui reste à l'Élysée c'est
bientôt l'époque des cerises ils le
mettent dans l'arbre ça fait fuir les
moineaux
toujours dans match François Bayrou et
ses 6 enfants qui n'ont pas couché entre
eux c'est Philippe de Villiers ou les
enfants se tripotent prenez des notes la
semaine prochaine on pourra plus parler
politique et c'est important que vous
ayez toutes les infos pour voter
écologie trois ans après la catastrophe
de l'Erika certaines plages bretonnes
restent souillées
ça ne part pas c'est une vraie saloperie
ça pollue tout ce que ça touche
voilà
c'est important que vous ayez toutes les
infos pour aller voter à la semaine
prochaine merci
le plongeur en apnée Loïc Le ferme meurt
à l'entraînement faut remonter à la
surface sinon le record ne compte pas à
la Fédération d'apnée durant le tsunami
ils ont reçu des centaines de lettres
oui mon mari restait qu'un jour sous
l'eau pouvez-vous homologuer ce nouveau
record non remonter
anthropologie les cheveux de Ramsès II
restitués à l'Égypte on est sûr que ce
sont les siens si on a déjà fait une
boulette avec Jeanne d'Arc il y a un
autre égyptien célèbre ici c'est Orlando
et si on restitue ces implants
capillaires à l'Égypte ça va gueuler
gérontologie Michel Drucker embauche
madame de Fontenay comme chroniqueuse
Drucker toujours dans Télé 2 Semaines
Michel nous présente ses trois fifilles
Olga virgule et son préféré Stéphane
caniche royal à poil bouclés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
showbize caisse Richard déclare avoir
sniffé les cendres de son père avec de
la cocaïne il paraît qu'on prend la
personnalité du mort donc gynéco a dû
sniffer un gros naze
neko saliagas Chevalier des Arts et des
Lettres
heureusement que le gouvernement va
changer qu'un jour de plus c'est Steevy
était décoré
Formule 1 en 2009 le Grand Prix de
France pourrait avoir lieu à Paris oui
c'est la dernière torture imaginée par
de la Noé toute l'année on fait du 2 à
l'heure et une fois par an on se fera
narguer par des bolites qui vont à 350
Joachim Noah rebelle comme son père
titre VSD voici la photo d'un rebelle en
slip slogie
c'est impressionnant
Pascal Sevran condamnée par les
prud'hommes à payer 30000 euros à son
jardinier une brouille idiote là vous
les couper la [ __ ] des noirs et l'autre
uniquement tailler les rosiers
et on termine avec William Leymergie
chevalier de la Légion d'Honneur gentil
en avion paye son jardinier c'est le
seul type bien qu'ils aient trouvé à
France 2 à la semaine prochaine
vous avez suivi un petit peu les
candidats après le après le premier tour
c'est pas triste alors on commence par
un moment d'émotion mardi au QG du FN
Marine tient la main de son papa avant
son départ en maison de retraite
l'hospice long séjour accueillera
Jean-Marie mots croisés pétanque et
soirée théâtrale avec Dieudonné
en exclusivité les premières photos de
Jean-Marie allospice là l'infirmière lui
tend ses pilules il grimace un peu plus
tard en survêt pour l'animation poterie
et macramé et voici ces deux camarades
de Chambray Geneviève et Marie-Louise
qu'il vient de nommer responsable de la
section Déambulateur et son urinaire
on termine par une photo de sa fille
sortant de l'hospice marine visiblement
soulagée de cette débarrassée du vieux
le leader frontiste furieux contre
Nicolas Sarkozy qui l'accuse de plagiat
c'est un peu vrai quand Jean-Marie rend
hommage au cowboy de brognac Mountain 15
jours plus tard Nicolas limite regardez
la position du bras c'est bon une
élection rude qui laisse des séquelles
depuis dimanche Philippe de Villiers se
promène avec un drapeau français sur la
tête
au Jardin d'Acclimatation Dominique
Voynet refuse de quitter la rivière
enchantée
plus grave François Bayrou continue à
faire campagne dans un aéroport il donne
la colade à des militants absents
un peu plus tard il s'est adressé deux
heures à décadis orange la couleur de
son parti après les larmes le réconfort
Nicolas Hulot console de Munich voisnet
en lui touchant les seins
Nicolas qui a l'habitude des missions
difficiles
et puis un beau geste François Bayrou
amoureux des chiots pardonne à la
monture de Nicolas Sarkozy tu es une
belle [ __ ] lui aurait-il murmuré
autre homogeste le cadeau de consolation
de Vincent Lindon à François Bayrou un
tracteur Smoby avec sa remorque
après les larmes les regrets Dominique
wanez s'interroge voteriez-vous pour moi
si j'étais séropositive non en aucun cas
on aurait voté pour vous à deux pas de
regrets Dominique
émotion toujours vendredi Chirac a
répété son départ de l'Élysée très belle
prestation de Line Renaud
les Chirac ont trouvé un toit 180 m² en
duplex on respire Jacques ne sera pas au
même étage que Bernadette et David
Douillet pourra venir en passant par
l'escalier de service
une image de liesse Neuilly a fêté son
champion une fête énorme qui a failli
dégénérer bien ecstasy à gogo ce sont
les deux pourcents de logements sociaux
qui ont foutu la merde
et on termine par un scoop Philippe
Torreton et Ségolène le début d'une
romance
à quelques minutes après un entretien
privé avec l'acteur une rose est tombée
de la culotte de Ségolène
quel poète se Philippe à la semaine
prochaine
[Applaudissements]
ça va ça va bien
et on commence par cette initiative des
magasins Bricorama qui dès dimanche on
saluer la victoire de Nicolas Sarkozy
autre beau geste la compagnie Ryanair
offre 50 000 billets d'avion pour fêter
le nouveau président dans 15 jours la
compagnie Air France offrira 500000
billets à nos amis sans papiers
direction Bamako
une victoire ça s'arrose Nicolas a enfin
passé une nuit entière avec Cécilia un
exploit ovationné par le personnel du
Fouquet sous la forme d'une haie
d'honneur il est vraiment il est
vraiment très nommé
tout ça pour ça
à propos du Fouquet sur TF1 PPDA
s'enflammait c'est une formidable pub
pour ce restaurant qui fait hôtel depuis
peu Patrick n'est pas forcé d'évoquer sa
vie privée à l'antenne
[Applaudissements]
un quinquennat a démarré en trombe dès
dimanche une première mesure très
courageuse faire redécouvrir à la France
la chanteuse préférée de Stéphane Bern
enfin une consolation si Ségolène avait
gagné c'est Romane Serda qui aurait
chanté la Marseillaise on a eu chaud
je peux pas maintenant
parti socialiste on sait enfin ce qui
s'est dit dimanche rue de Solférino
entre Sego et François moi aussi je veux
passer nuit au Fouquet ça t'elle dit pas
question tu as perdu on rentre à la
maison
et puis un document rarissime le seul
sourire de DSK durant toute la campagne
c'était dimanche quand il a glissé un
bulletin Sarkozy dans l'urne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
8 mai 45 dernières commémoration pour
Jacques Chirac on s'est emmerdé dépôt
d'une gerbe accolade aux anciens
combattants l'année prochaine on fêtera
ça au Fouquet champagne à gogo [ __ ] et
karaoké
[Applaudissements]
des traces de cou sur l'un des bébés oui
il y avait deux boîtes de pizza au
fromage qui bloquaient l'entrée du
congélo donc madame courgeot a dû passer
bébé en force
musique cette mort lors d'un concert de
la star academy tunisienne oui là-bas il
vote et après ils zigouille les perdants
ça évite qu'il fasse un disque deux ans
plus tard Nolwenn en Tunisie ce serait
fini depuis longtemps
excuse-moi
je le pense pas c'est juste
un grand bravo journal Le Parisien pour
ce titre ils n'ont pas fait exprès je
précise mode de points une ligne pocket
[Applaudissements]
et on termine on termine avec notre jeu
de la semaine l'adieu de Bernadette
Chirac à Rostropovitch où est le
macchabée
envoyez vos réponses à la semaine
prochaine merci beaucoup c'est joli
lundi de la Pentecôte rien pas de vanne
je refuse de travailler pour les vieux
c'est confirmé MAM a une haleine de bouc
un scoop si Ségolène avait gagné
François Hollande avait lu aussi réservé
un yacht un peu moins cher que celui de
Bolloré 78 euros et 60 de centimes
style flash si tu bandes pas c'est moins
grave
[Applaudissements]
Nicolas Sarkozy à bord du futur A380 qui
pourra je le rappelle transporter 830
100 papiers d'un coup
Nicolas a testé une nouvelle manette un
système de trappe pour évacuer en plein
vol
les récalcitrantes c'est plus humain
voilà
et dans les Pyrénées une belle image de
solidarité une voiture sinistrée s'est
échoué au pied d'un homme politique
sinistre aussi
faits divers la belle fille de Nicolas
Sarkozy renversée par un scooter et on a
enfin un portrait robot du chauffard
voilà
[Applaudissements]
imitateur en herbe attention et là je
m'adresse à Liane Foly en Corse du Sud
de zimitations de Mike Brant on tournait
au drame
là on va monter en pression
artificielle encore des progrès à faire
dans match Céline Dion nous présente son
fils
[Applaudissements]
sport Laure Manaudou blessé au doigt de
pied son ex entraîneur est furieux un
accident prévisible selon lui et
regardez ces images en pleine séance
d'apnée le nageur italien qui a quitté
sa ligne d'eau lui écrase leur taille
leur alourdit par les deux sacs de McDo
qu'elle vient de s'enfiler n'a plus
éviter le choc
showbiz Yannick Noah pourquoi je reste
en France réponse parce que j'ai pas les
couilles de partir
[Applaudissements]
n'est pas une girouette dans Le Parisien
du 25 mai Roland-Garros je m'en fous et
dans le VSD du 26 mai Yannick Noah
raconte son langage
[Applaudissements]
le canard est doté d'un pénis de 30 cm
une info qui est une info qui a fait
beaucoup de mal à Stéphane
Bernard
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a des fables de Stéphane
il y en a deux à Orly drame évitez de
justesse une vieille chouette failli
boucher un réacteur
[Applaudissements]
télévision Line Renaud et Arditi réunies
dans une série pour France 2 ok ok je
bosserai pour les vieux à la Pentecôte
c'est le premier mais en échange que les
vieux arrêtent de bosser voilà
c'est fini demain c'est la fête des
mères Michel Alliot-Marie et Amanda Lear
c'est dans 15 jours pour la fête des
pères
[Applaudissements]
société pêche illégale de thon au large
des côtes françaises Évelyne Thomas est
monté au créneau laissez-moi nager
tranquille
nasal lors des vols spatiaux les
excréments serviront d'énergie
électrique seul bémol si l'équipage est
constipé la navette ralentie
ça s'amusera mon fils qui est en CP
une info pour Geneviève de Fontenay une
japonaise élue Miss Univers une édition
2007 riche bon quelques déceptions Miss
Liban c'était une prise une requête Miss
Darfour trauma les chars ne tient pas
miss Randa plus de bras impossible de
mettre sa couronne toute seule Miss
Belgique la plus con n'est pas forcément
la plus belle
miss Kaboul très jolie mais entièrement
voilée attention attention piège si vous
sortez avec Miss Kaboul et que vous
ressentez une douleur au bas des reins
c'est peut-être Mister Kaboul
[Applaudissements]
faits divers en Corrèze arrestation d'un
gérontophile oui un jeune maçon violet
les vieilles dames grosse déception de
Bernadette Chirac qui court attirer
l'attention s'habille en jaune
[Applaudissements]
sport Guiraud entraînera le FC Lens
c'est le transfert de l'année une
tondeuse neuve de survêtement moule les
trois packs de cristallines
Guy Roux pourtant savourait sa retraite
je le cite le matin quand je me lève je
n'ai plus 25 gaillards sur le dos une
phrase attribue à tort à Pascal Sevran
à ce propos quel est le point commun
entre Guy Roux et Claudia Schiffer
ils ont fait tous les deux une pub
Citroën sauf que pour Guy roule l'airbag
n'est pas sorti
Manaudou Philippe Lucas a engagé une
nageuse roumaine la nageuse roumaine tu
peux la tabasser la laisser 24 heures
dans l'eau tout le monde s'en fout tu
balances une pièce de temps en temps
costume de Michael Jackson 19000 dollars
pour une veste en revanche le pantalon
n'est pas parti une braguette avec des
boutons en forme de Mickey sanamus que
les enfants
[Rires]
dernière minute madame Stallone n'ira
pas en vacances sur la Côte d'Azur oui
je voulais dire la pêche au thon a
repris
suivez un minimum quand même
[Applaudissements]
et on termine par l'adieu à Jean-Claude
Brialy une cérémonie très émouvante
corps et pu commenter Frédéric
Mitterrand
bonsoir
pour rendre hommage au prince de la
nouvelle vague dans des iconoclastes
cynique des cinémas français je cite
toutes les conneries que j'ai lu dans
Gala nos plus grandes stars c'était mise
sur leur 31
Marc-Olivier Fogiel habillé pour
l'occasion en croque-mort un costume qui
lui va si bien offrait son bras à Claire
Chazal toujours en deuil de Philippe
Torreton Catherine Deneuve elle arborait
un improbable pu la rayure gagnée
vraisemblablement dans une soirée La
Halle aux vêtements
Dominique bessenard habillé en noir sa
mincit renonça au dernier moment à
prononcer le raisons funèbre son cheveu
sur la langue
déclenchantillarité mais sans doute le
plus bel hommage fut l'arrivée impromptu
dans tout petit homme haut comme une
écrevisse frère % de Mimie Mathy le
président Sarkozy
gajon que Jean-Claude observateur aigu
de la Comédie humaine aurait goûté
pleinement cette cérémonie bonsoir merci
[Applaudissements]
qui vient de faire là c'est très
difficile parce que au fond profond
d'ailleurs en vérité tout le monde est
horriblement triste de la mort de
Jean-Claude Brialy bon et en même temps
caricaturer Fredo comme ça sur ce sujet
là ça pouvait être très casse-gueule et
en vérité c'était poétique stevenus
élection législative en Belgique
Yves le terme remporte 31% des voix sans
on a le droit d'en parler tout le monde
s'en fout mais on parlait alors à ce
propos je vous ai fait trois infos on
s'en fout mais on peut en parler
Stéphane Bern adore le sport hippique 9
suisses sur 10 possède un téléphone
portable
par essilton refuse de déféquer aux
toilettes
société Clichy interdit les mini moto ça
c'est dégueulasse pour les gens de
petite taille parce que eux c'est leur
moto normal Mimie Mathy ou d'autres mais
bon soyez
la pêche au thon continue Evelyne Thomas
toujours en danger
une info gala Sylvie Vartan avec le
temps je deviens plus fragile c'est
normal Sylvie c'est l'ostéoporose
sport selon la société Philips se raser
c'est comme piloter une Formule 1 et ça
c'est qu'en Franck Ribéry se rase
en tout cas
c'est un super rasoir Amanda lire la
commande est demain pour la fête des
pères bonne fête Amanda
télévision à Paris Emmanuel Chain
organise le premier salon du petit écran
plusieurs stands le Jean-Luc de la rue
le Sébastien Cauet
le Michel Drucker
le Thierry Ardisson
et enfin très attendu le standard Pascal
Sevran
on termine ce salon avec une nouveauté
qui devrait intéresser André Manoukian
une nouvelle star à l'envers on vote
pour que des chanteurs connus
redeviennent anonymes alors ça
donnerait ça oui tu t'appelles comment
Mathieu Mireille vas-y on t'écoute stop
Manu catcher tu en penses quoi écoute
Mireille si j'ai envie d'écouter Piaf je
me fais pas chier je vais acheter
l'album à la FNAC physiquement tu es
coiffé comme un playmobil en plus tu es
la chanteuse préférée de Stéphane Bern
ça fait trois raisons tu dégages suivant
Régine Marianne commentaire pardon je
suis très ému j'ai des petites larmes
est devenue chanter dans l'état où tu es
une chanson de Madonna en plus
manu a eu très peur que comme elle tu
balances ta culotte au public tu l'as
pas fait merci fais juste gaffe quand tu
bouges au fil de ta personne
[Applaudissements]
quoi j'ai rien entendu André
moi je trouve que tu as une voix sublime
sublime sublime sublime le fait que tu
fasses 85 60 86 ça donne à ta voix un
grain extraordinaire je vais te laisser
mon portable qu'on en parle
tranquillement ce soir à la maison par
contre quand tu arrives tape sur
l'interphone avec le point sinon je
t'entendrai pas
merci
rebonsoir donc pour cette dernière
j'avais décidé de remettre des prises
Stéphane parce que sans nos amis people
je ne serai rien j'ai voulu les
remercier à ma manière le prix du
courage revient à Nicolas Hulot qui pour
dénoncer la reprise de la pêche au thon
à peloter Dominique Voynet
prix remis également à titre posthume à
Rostropovitch embrassé dans son cercueil
par Bernadette Chirac
pour la petite histoire Jacques a
immédiatement rendu la monnaie de sa
pièce à Bernadette en embrassant lui
aussi une momie
le prix de la grande froideur très
disputé execo les salariés de la société
Picard et les deux bébés courgeaux
non il y a des prix c'est très difficile
de trancher par exemple le prix de la
laine de bouc entre la jument de
François Bayrou Bernard Kouchner ou MAM
c'était très difficile de trouver
[Applaudissements]
prix du fayot va Robert Robert permet au
président de franchir tous les obstacles
et sur cette deuxième photo le président
a tant que Robert lui apporte un cube
pour poser ses jambes merci Robert
le prix de la rupture Ségolène et
François ils avaient tout pour être
heureux Ségolène imitait Bécassine comme
personne
François juré partout qu'il en avait une
grosse le jour de leur rencontre il
s'était offert le même attaché case
facétieux François glissait parfois une
rose dans la culotte de sa moitié
aujourd'hui c'est gaunois son chagrin
dans l'alcool et François s'est acheté
un nouveau costume pour [ __ ]
prix de la plus belle imitation Jacques
Chirac dans question pour un champion
protégé par mon immunité parlementaire
durant 12 ans je suis à nouveau un
citoyen ordinaire qui qui suis-je
ouais
super
[Applaudissements]
le prix de la camaraderie François
Fillon il aime tellement Sarkozy qui
chope la migraine à sa place
le prix nozer bon ou pris qui pue
Georges fresh Pascal Sevran et Dieudonné
à égalité
le prix du trade
impossible à décerner cette année trop
de monde on passe
on termine par les prix qui ne bougent
pas chaque année il
conserve x douloureux pour eux
prix de l'animateur le plus antipathique
prix du micro pénis
prix de l'encéphalogramme plat
une exception quand même le prix de la
plus belle morsure sultan le chien qui
avait mordu Isabelle dinoir 700 titres à
Jean-Luc Delarue
et enfin
dernier prix remis à titre personnel le
prix de la sympathie va à toute l'équipe
de terriens merci beaucoup merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu